[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENRY WEI: Christina was
trained by Kim West, the sleep
lady in her Gentle
Sleep Coach program.
This is a program
that involves dozens
of hours of training and
exam and participation
in case supervision.
Christina Gantcher also
complete advanced training
for younger babies about
four or five months of age.
Her educational
backgrounds includes
a BA in comparative
literature from UMass
and a masters of science in
psychoanalytic developmental
psychology from
University College London.
She is a mother of two boys
and lives in New York City
with her husband Mike Gantcher.
She had the good fortune
to work with Kim West
personally when her older
son had sleep difficulties.
Find out more at
Christina's website
goodnightssleepcoaching.com.
That's
Without further ado, Christina.
Thanks.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, everyone.
It's a pleasure to be here.
And as you can see on the
title of my presentation,
my goal here is to help
everybody become sleep smart
and to really help
you understand
why certain things happen
or don't happen in terms
of your child and sleep.
And I used this
subtitle for a while,
but I thought it was fitting
that it is still in play
because ultimately,
becoming sleep smart
is really what you really need
to know about your child's
sleep because you've actually
exhausted the Google search
engine as well as yourself.
So there are really three
parts to this presentation.
We're going to talk about
some basic sleep science.
Then I'm going to get into
the most common challenges
and problems parents
find with their child
and sleep and then
talk about solutions.
So in terms of common myths,
the most popular common myths
I confront in my
work are that babies
will sleep when they are
12 pounds and 12 weeks.
Wrong.
There is no medical
research to back that up.
Number two, babies will
sleep through the night
when they start solids.
Wrong again.
Food does not have anything to
do with sleep or sleeping well.
And third, if you put
your baby to sleep late,
they will sleep long and
longer in the morning,
which is the key there.
That is also false,
unfortunately.
And we'll talk about
why that is the case.
If there's only
one thing that you
will remember from
this talk, I want you
to remember this at all times.
That sleep is actually
a learned skill.
Some babies will
simply find it easier,
and others will find
it more challenging.
And there's a number
of reasons that is.
But it's always
important to remember
that it's a learned
skill just like crawling,
walking, talking.
All of those are learned skills.
Secondly, sleep is a
neurological development.
And most babies are ready to
sleep through the night, as we
say, around six months.
And we'll get into the
details of that in a minute.
And lastly on the slide,
I want to highlight
that there's great
variability about when
babies are ready to
sleep through the night.
And I say that because there's
so much information out
there and so many books that
promise parents things that
are simply the case for maybe
20% or 30% of the population.
But if you're in 70% to
80% of the population,
it doesn't really
matter, does it?
So I always highlight
that variability
because some babies
may be ready to do
that sleeping through the
night earlier than others,
and some later.
And that's OK.
So in terms of talking
about sleep science,
technically, there is no
sleeping through the night.
Now if you're a parent
who has a sleep challenge,
you're probably
going, you're right.
There is no sleeping
through the night.
I haven't gotten
to that point yet.
But I say this
because it's actually
normal for every person to
have several night wakings.
That's a brain function.
Everybody wakes up
several times a night.
The issue is if you know how
to put yourself to sleep,
you can do it all
night long, as it were.
On a completely
neurological level--
and I'm simplifying this
for today's purpose--
we have two kinds of sleep.
We have deep sleep
and active sleep.
We begin our night sleep going
into non-REM sleep, which is
our deepest stretch of sleep.
And then in the
middle of the night--
and when I say
middle of the night,
that means sometime between,
let's say, 12:00 and 3:00 AM--
we shift gears very
much like a car
and go into active
and light sleep.
And lastly, in terms of
the science piece of this,
I want to highlight, again,
there is no scientific proof
that food will help your
baby sleep better or well.
And that doesn't mean we're
talking about milk or solids.
Again, thinking about sleep
as a neurological development,
a brain development
that goes on a fairly
consistent and structured path
is important to keep in mind.
Common issues.
You are not alone.
So I would say the
things that I tend
to help parents with the
most are the following.
My baby goes to sleep very
easily, but wakes several times
a night.
Right?
So dealing with night
wakings, very common.
My baby needs to be
nursed or rocked or fed
to sleep all night long.
Again, several times a night.
I hear very often from
parents, particularly babies
under six months,
my baby will only
sleep being held or co-sleeping.
And then lastly,
my baby won't nap.
Naps can be very challenging
for many children,
particularly after a certain
age because of development
for a variety of reasons.
So what's normal, right?
Because that's really important
to understand, particularly
when you've got your next
door neighbor saying,
well, my kid's been
sleeping through the night
for the past several months.
I don't know what's
going on with you.
But it's very important to
understand what is normal.
The age of the baby is really
important to keep in mind.
So developmental age is very
important in respect to sleep.
And whether the baby was
born pre-term, right?
So before 40 weeks or
early, because sleep
definitely goes on a
development after 40 weeks.
So if your baby
was born pre-term,
even if it's only
a few weeks, it's
not that there's a problem.
It's that they simply may not
get to certain development
sleep wise until they
hit different milestones.
Are there any medical
conditions, right?
So the most common
medical conditions
that tend to stand in the way
of sleep are things like reflux,
or GERD, any ENT difficulties,
such as enlarged adenoids
or tonsils, any type of
breathing difficulty.
Is there a family
history of any of this?
And then lastly, also
anemia, low iron stores
can disturb sleep.
So all of those things are
very important to keep in mind
if you are confronting a sleep
challenge with your child.
And in terms of young babies,
I want to highlight that babies
under five months--
OK?
Feeding is more
important than sleeping.
And the reason I say that
is because, again, there's
a lot of information
out there that says,
well, by 12 pounds in
12 weeks, your baby
doesn't need to eat at night.
Some may not.
I would say the vast majority
still may need to eat at night.
And so feeding
really comes first
for those first four to five
months in my estimation.
We need to make sure that
that's going perfectly.
And if it's not for some
reason, we definitely
want to have parents talk
to their pediatrician
and/or a lactation consultant
to rule out any type of feeding
difficulty for the child.
Again, think about
what's normal.
The American Academy
of Pediatrics
states that babies
under six months
may not have regular
sleep patterns.
Now, many will present
regular sleep patterns,
but this gives you the idea that
there's a big range of normal.
And that's OK.
And in terms of
the AAP guidelines
in terms of how much your
child needs on a daily basis,
they recently reviewed
them about two years ago
and put out new guidelines
in terms of averages,
about 17 to 14 hours a day
for babies under 12 months.
Now, it's important
to keep in mind
that in these first
few months, babies
are going to sleep
short stretches
and be awake short stretches.
So those first few months, we're
talking about short windows.
So again, to go over
sleeping through the night,
because that tends to be
what most of us as parents
are looking for.
To say again, there is no
sleeping through the night,
but children need to
understand and remember
how they fall asleep because
that is the skill we're
looking for all night long.
And then of course
later for naps as well.
And so the way a baby knows
how to fall asleep at bedtime
becomes the foundation
of what they're going
to look for all night long.
So to highlight one problem that
many parents face, and I just
like to tease out a little
bit, I talked to many parents,
particularly at this time
of year or in May who say,
my child wakes up every
single day at 5 AM.
Now, of course, with sunrise
so early this time of year,
that can be due to too much
light in the child's room
too early.
But I'd like to highlight
the difference between night
wakings and early rising because
many children tend to get up
very early in the morning.
And so night wakings happen
any time after bedtime
and are usually due to too late
of a bed time, the baby being
put to bed asleep already,
and also nap deprivation.
So either naps that are too
short or just poorly timed
can cause night wakings.
Now, in terms of early rising--
which I define as waking
consistently at 5:00
AM or really any time
in that, let's say, 4:30
to before 6:00 AM time--
that also usually
happens because bedtime
is too late, because
of nap deprivation,
and/or a medical condition.
So there are certain
medical conditions,
particularly the
breathing difficulties,
that can cause early rising.
So I just like to highlight
the differences there
because they can be
different although similarly
related problems.
Naps.
So naps are really important
for children basically three
years and under.
And it's really chicken
and egg in the sense
that nighttime sleep affects
daytime sleep, and vise versa.
So many times, naps
will not be great
until nighttime
sleep gets better.
But conversely, naps
may not be great
because nighttime
sleep is a problem.
So in many ways, bedtime
is the foundation
of how your child
understands to sleep.
We then build on it with
proper nighttime sleep,
and then naps will usually
fall into place last.
And so I like to highlight that
as well because many people
have questions with their
children in terms of naps
because they change
so much from,
let's say, 6 months to 12
months to 18 months to beyond.
And in terms of when
children will stop napping,
it tends to be sometime between
the third and fourth year
of life.
So now, talking about solutions.
One of the most important
things I talk to parents about
is crib acclimatization.
And what that means
is your child really
needs to understand where
you expect them to sleep.
So imagine last night,
you went to bed.
And you distinctly remember
the washing up process,
or taking a shower, or getting
into bed thinking, oh God.
Thank goodness.
And then you find
yourself waking up
in the middle of
your kitchen floor.
And you think, wait, no, it was
not a crazy, wonderful night
last night.
This should not have happened.
How did I end up here?
And that sort of
out-of-body experience
I don't know who moved me is
what your child will experience
when they are transferred.
And at some age, that transfer
tends to stop working.
Now what does that mean?
I put my baby to
sleep here in my arms.
It's all wonderful and cozy.
I transfer him into the crib.
But then he wakes
up two hours later
and is screaming bloody murder,
and I'm not really sure why.
Well, one of the reasons
is because he doesn't
remember getting into the crib.
So that's really important.
So making sure that your
child spend some time
during the day--
I usually suggest few
minutes in the morning,
a few minutes in the
afternoon while they're awake.
Chilling out, relaxing, hanging
out in their sleep space
so that it is not
a surprise to them
when they are asked to go to
sleep in that place later on.
And if you heard me say go to
sleep in that place later on,
ultimately, we want our children
to go to sleep in their crib.
Not in our arms, not
bouncing on a ball,
not being held,
because we want them
to experience falling asleep
where they should stay asleep.
So getting them used
to their sleep space,
acclimating them a little bit
each day is really important.
I usually suggest
this as a first step
in getting out of any
kind of sleep challenge
with your child.
Next.
Again, in terms of
when a young baby is
ready to sleep
through the night,
that baby is eating
every three or four
hours throughout a night.
Well, that's not
going to happen if--
sleeping through
the night is not
going to happen obviously
if they're still
eating very frequently.
So most babies will
be ready to go a night
stretch without
sleeping sometime
between six and nine months.
But that's something to speak
to the pediatrician about.
And ask the doctor, is my
baby ready to sleep 10, 11, 12
hours without a feed?
That's something they should
be coordinating with you
and really relating to in
terms of their growth chart
and how they're gaining weight.
And of course, there
are different methods
of night weaning that
the doctor should
be able to guide you about,
or your lactation consultant
if [INAUDIBLE] And
then also figure out
if my baby is feeding to
sleep, then obviously,
we change that association
first at bedtime
so that then throughout the
night, we can be consistent.
So that word consistency.
Being consistent about any type
of sleep association behavior
is ultimately the most important
piece of changing things
if you're in a
challenger problem.
Because when a child
experiences inconsistency,
it's going to create crying.
It's just that simple.
They don't understand our words.
They understand our
behavior, right?
So having consistent
behavior is what
is going to get you
to the finish line.
So ultimately,
what's inconsistent?
Perfect example is
well, at bedtime, we
have our last bottle, and
the nursery is really dark,
and he usually just drifts
off, and then I transfer him.
But he's 10 months
old, and I really
don't think he needs
any food at night.
So when he wakes up
around 12:00 or 1:00,
I just go in and sort of
pat his back to sleep,
and he goes back to
sleep pretty quickly.
But then, of course, he wakes
up at 3 o'clock in the morning,
and I just can't take it,
so I bring him into my bed.
That's a perfect example
of inconsistent behavior
because that child never knows
am I going to get fed to sleep?
Is somebody just
going to pat my back?
Or am I just going to
come into bed with them?
So in some ways, having
one thing to undo is easier
and ultimately, of course,
being consistent about having
the baby fall asleep in their
crib is what we're looking for.
Now in terms of methods, right?
Because there are lots of
different books out there
and lots of information
about how to change things.
There's basically
three behavioral ways
of changing a sleep challenge.
There's extinction, which
is well known as cry it out.
And that essentially
is the method
of putting my child in
her crib at bedtime,
I say good night, I
leave, and that's it
until whatever time in
the morning you decide.
That means no
checking, no nothing.
And that's why we
call it cry it out.
It does tend to be very popular.
And if it works, it
works pretty quickly.
It should work fairly quickly.
The person who sort of
coined the methodology,
Dr. Marc Weissbluth, has said it
doesn't work for all children.
So if you find
yourself in a situation
where it doesn't seem to be
getting better pretty quickly,
you definitely want to
change tack and course.
Next, time checks.
Time checks are basically
graduated extinction
and were really made popular
by Dr. Richard Ferber.
So ferberizing, as many people
know it as, basically goes
under the premise
of well, I'm going
to give my child the space and
time to calm themselves down.
Right?
So I'm going to put
the child in the crib,
leave, and then in
graduated time intervals,
quickly check on the
child, but ultimately
allow them to put
themselves to sleep.
So that means going in graduated
intervals, let's say 5 minutes,
10 minutes, 15 minutes
from the last check,
not from the beginning.
So you're not going
in every five minutes.
You're extending
those intervals.
And then lastly, feeding.
And feeding really means--
in some ways, I like to think
of it as a behavioral weaning.
So we're doing less and less
to assist the child as he
or she falls asleep and
then work our way away
in physical space.
So those are sort of the
most popular methodologies
out there to have your
child get to sleep
and sleep well
through the night.
And again, as I said
before, I always
want to encourage parents
to start at bedtime,
work on night time, and
then work on naps last.
It just tends to be the most
effective way for things
to change efficiently
and most easily.
And of course, if
all else fails,
please feel free to contact me.
I work with families
across the country
and world at this point.
And if not, we have a network
of gentle sleep coaches
which are out there ready
to help tired parents.
HENRY WEI: All right.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much, Christina.
We're going to take some
questions and answers.
So go ahead and join those
microphones or [INAUDIBLE]
baby sleep Dory.
And we've already got some
great questions up here,
and I suspect we're going
to hear echoes of what
you've recommended already.
First one is "My son
is 15 months old,
and we can't get him to sleep at
night without a falling asleep
while drinking his
bottle, and then
putting him in his crib asleep.
Do you have any tips for how we
can put him down awake for him
to fall asleep on his own?
Thank you."
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK, great.
So I would want to know
what time bedtime is.
Let's say-- I'm
just going to say
it's between 7:00
and 8:00 PM, which
tends to be a pretty popular
and good time for most young
children to be going to sleep.
We want to back that
last feeding up,
meaning let's do
it earlier in time,
let's make sure it's
in a well-lit room.
Again, not a sleepy, dark room
that's going to make the child
want to fall asleep.
And also think about it,
15 months, is that bottle
necessary?
Is it something that has been a
problem for the child in terms
of gaining weight?
Is it the pediatrician
should be guiding
about having maybe a cup
or a straw cup with dinner
or slightly after dinner not in
that sleepy dark state, which
is going to make the
baby want to fall asleep?
HENRY WEI: All right, cool.
Let's takes some
audience questions.
We'll go to right over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you so much for your talk.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: My pleasure.
AUDIENCE: It is actually
somewhat related
to the question from the Dory.
I have an 11-month-old
right now who
for from six to eight months, we
had a very, very solid bedtime
routine.
Always put him down awake.
But then teething came, and
he was sick for two months.
And so there was a lot
of exceptions made.
And now we're at a point where
basically every night, we
do dinner, bath
time, bottle, bed,
and he falls asleep
on the bottle.
And he actually does wake
up a little bit right
as we're putting
him into the crib,
and then he goes to sleep.
But he's sleeping 11 and
1/2 to 12 hours a night.
And so we're like, it's
all working, so don't--
if it ain't broke, don't fix it.
But we're a little concerned
that that association
has crept back in.
And so any thoughts?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
Well, what time
does he wake up in the morning?
AUDIENCE: Between 6:30 and 7:00.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
And how are naps?
AUDIENCE: Great.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: So--
[LAUGHS] right.
So if it's not
broke, don't fix it.
What I will say is it
is working right now,
so I wouldn't worry about it.
If you find that something
starts going wrong--
night wakings or
protesting nap time--
again, have that last
bottle in a well-lit sort
of public space, right?
The kitchen, the
living room, someplace
that's not going to make
him want to fall asleep.
Because on a scale of 1 to
10, 1 is awake, 10 is asleep.
You want to put your child
in the crib at a 5 or a 6,
not an 8 or 9 because
that's really remembering.
If you're at 8 or 9,
maybe kind of not really.
And then all of a
sudden, 2:00 AM comes.
Well, I don't really
remember how I got here.
So we really want to make sure
that they have that experience
and that memory.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
HENRY WEI: Thanks
for your question.
Another question in this dark,
quiet, and comfortable room.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
HENRY WEI: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I want the
other guy's problem.
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: So my son's
actually almost five,
and he started sleeping really
quite well around eight months.
But around a year or
so ago, he started
waking up in the night around--
I don't know--
between two and four.
And then we have a baby monitor
in the room, so he cries,
and I come up.
And usually he goes back
to sleep pretty quickly.
And I've started trying,
you know, what's the matter?
Are you having a nightmare?
[MUMBLES] And it's always,
I don't know, and you know.
It's OK, you don't have to be--
and I can't-- he just keeps
waking up in the night,
and I can't kind of connect with
him to figure out what's going
on.
And I don't know whether
it's he can't express it or--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: --what.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Does he
have any history of ear, nose,
and throat difficulties
like tubes in the ears,
lots of ear infections,
sinus stuff?
Or is there any
family history of it?
AUDIENCE: He had reactive airway
disorder when he was young,
but it's not nearly as bad,
and it doesn't really seem--
tends to only be in the winter.
And this problem doesn't
correlate with the season.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: I'm a
horrible sleeper.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
And is that because of any ear,
nose, or throat stuff yourself?
AUDIENCE: No, I think I'm
psychologically damaged
or something.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
So you know-- and, oh.
And lastly, so four years old.
Is he dry at night?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
And what time is bedtime?
AUDIENCE: 8:30 to 9:00
usually, sometimes 9:30.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
And what time
does he get up in the morning?
AUDIENCE: 7:00.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: The
first thing I would do
is move bedtime.
Lights out 8:00, 8:30
latest because we still
have to anticipate for enough
time for him to fall asleep.
That extra sort of half an hour,
45 minutes that he's taking
may just be a little
too late for him.
Kids at that age have
really busy lives.
Their imaginations
are running rampant.
They've got a lot on their mind.
So I would definitely
give more time
to get him to fall
asleep earlier.
The other thing is I would just
keep an eye on any breathing
difficulty.
Does he breathe
with his mouth open?
Does he ever have
any trouble that way?
Because night wakings tend to
be at that hour consistently
inconsistent can be some
type of medical issue, which
he may outgrow.
Tonsils and adenoids tend
to grow exponentially large
in children between
the ages of 2 and 5.
So that may subside as his
facial structure catches up.
But it may not.
So definitely want
to keep an eye
on that with a pediatrician
or a visit to the ENT.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So because I'm a
bad sleeper, I'm
also awake when I
hear him wake up.
And it sounds like he's afraid.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
And so that fear,
I mean, some of it
could be an active imagination.
Some of it can be if
your breathing stops
or is interrupted, it's very
scary to wake up to that.
So any type of apnea
that may be going on
because he has some type of
obstruction can be very scary.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I hadn't thought of that.
HENRY WEI: Thanks.
Over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
So I have a 3-year-old.
And he takes an
afternoon nap most days,
but some days he
fights it or just
doesn't want to
sleep or whatever.
How do we know when it's time
to give up on the napping?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: And so
three years and how many months?
AUDIENCE: Like three months.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
So he's probably
in this stage of maybe sort of.
Which means, let's say,
three or four days a week,
he could still really use a nap.
But then the other days,
he's got enough energy
to keep going.
So unfortunately, it's not--
the transition out of a
nap is rarely one week here
and one week there.
It tends to progress
over let's just say
several months, two
to three months.
Where, again, he may need a
nap for a few days in a row
and be compliant,
and then he's just
got enough energy not
to for several days.
So I can't say that
there's a day you're going
to know when he won't need it.
My guess is he's going to show
you by his mood and energy
level.
When children do
stop napping, bedtime
tends to get earlier
because, of course,
they're just so tired
by the end of the day.
So you want to
keep that in mind.
And you can always
just enforce rest time.
OK, you don't have to sleep.
Just lay quietly, look
at a book quietly,
has to be a quiet time.
And you can set a timer
for 30 or 45 minutes.
You can also have a clock.
So one thing I love
for children I'd really
say 15 to 18 months and older,
developmental clocks are great.
There's lots of them out there.
There are colors, right?
Blue is for night,
yellow is for day.
It's not that your child
is going to tell time.
They're going to
understand this is bedtime,
and this is morning time.
And even for a nap, you can say
when the stop light says green,
you can come out from rest time.
So that might be
something helpful.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HENRY WEI: Great
question about naps.
Over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Thanks for coming.
I have kind of a
three part question.
[LAUGHS]
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
So go for it.
AUDIENCE: Different issues.
I have a daughter who will
be two at the end of May
and is still not sleeping
fully through the night.
We took her to an
ENT when she was
much younger to see if
she had an adenoid issue
or some other breathing issue.
And the feedback from the
doctor was her adenoids
are a little enlarged, but he
kind of said it's up to you
if you want to proceed
with the surgery.
So my first question
is around how do I--
or what's a good way to sort of
advocate for her a little bit
more in that field?
Is it just seeing
more specialists
or going to the pediatrician,
which we didn't see for this?
My second question is--
or maybe I could ask that first?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Sure.
Yeah.
So one of the hardest things
that I have found as a parent
myself is that ultimately,
it comes down to you.
And I've been in that
situation both personally
and professionally where
it becomes your decision
to do elective surgery.
I would always encourage parents
to see a second specialist,
get a second opinion, right?
And at the end of that, it does
become sort of your decision.
My feeling is always if
your child is not sleeping--
which means they are having
trouble growing essentially,
right?
Because we do grow
when we sleep--
and they're not breathing
well-- because ultimately,
things like that really come
down to breathing at some
level--
wouldn't you rather
help them out?
Particularly when we're talking
about things that are really
outpatient surgery, right?
So I would say definitely
a second opinion,
and then ultimately,
it comes down
to your gut instinct,
which tends to be right.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And the
other two questions
that I had were
around my daughter
still needs a bottle in
the middle of the night.
She sort of wakes
up, and I've tried
to change that behavior
by giving her a pacifier,
rubbing her back, et cetera.
She'll keep moaning and moaning
until she actually gets milk.
I've tried water in the bottle.
Nothing seems to be working.
Do you have any tips
to break that habit?
And finally, you mentioned
putting the child
into the crib.
My daughter can climb out
of her crib now, [LAUGHS]
so I worry about
her safety there.
So those are my two
other questions.
[LAUGHS]
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
So in terms of the bottle
at night, obviously,
that's just her way of
putting herself back to sleep.
Particularly at the age
of almost two years old,
there's no easy way except
saying tonight, no more bottle.
So with children, I'd say,
really after one-year-old,
we really want to tell
them what we're doing.
Doesn't have to be
a long soliloquy.
It should be short information.
Tonight, no more
bottles, to prepare
her sort of that afternoon
gives her a heads up.
And then having sort of several
days of a tough night, right?
Of tantrums in the
middle of the night,
but knowing that it will pass.
If magically all the bottles
in the world disappeared,
she would be OK.
And I would also
want to know related
to her adenoids, breathing,
all that kind of stuff,
she may be waking because
she's actually thirsty
because she's potentially
breathing through her mouth.
So that sort of supports your
case getting a second opinion
and trying to
understand why does she
wakes so frequently at night.
Some of it may, obviously,
is habit behaviorally,
but some of it may be
physical sort of dry mouth.
And then lastly, in terms of
climbing out of the crib, yes,
I am all too familiar with this.
One of the reasons
I am here today
is because my older son climbed
out of his crib at 18 months
after trying for many, many
months and landed on the floor.
And I said, OK,
we're done with this.
So there are different opinions
out there about when children
are ready to go from
a crib into a bed,
and ultimately, we
want them safe, right?
So a mattress on the
floor or a toddler
bed that's very low on
the ground is always OK.
But at that point,
we want to make
sure the room is the
crib safety wise, right?
So you need to completely
childproof their room.
And I always suggest a extra
tall safety gate for the door.
We don't want children
locked in their room,
and so a gate provides
communication, but safety.
So I would say that would
probably be your best bet.
HENRY WEI: Thanks
for your question.
And a reminder to
folks, Googlers,
you can go second opinion
for a benefits service
that you have available to you.
Or those watching on YouTube,
if you work for someone else,
you can ask your
employee benefits arm
if they have that
available to you.
All right, next
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
My wife is so jealous.
She wishes she could be here.
[LAUGHS]
So I'm going to try to channel
her with this question.
And it's basically, I have
a 3-year-old, 10 months.
And she wakes up often in
the middle of the night.
We put her to bed, start
the routine at 7:30.
She sleeps from
about 8:00 to 7:30.
And she'll wake up in
the middle of the night,
and she'll cry for mama.
And I'm like, it doesn't
bother me because she--
[LAUGHS] I mean, she doesn't--
if I try to go in there,
all hell breaks loose.
So my wife goes in
there, and then she's
able to get her to sleep.
But she's just had
it, and she wants
to just let her cry it out.
Is that OK to let a kid
that's 3, almost 4 years
old cry it out?
And if so, how should
we approach it?
How long-- you know?
And should I be going in there?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: So you
always have options, right?
There's no one magical path.
Otherwise, this would
all be very simple.
The cry it out proponents would
say, yes, of course it's fine.
There are different
methods of handling it.
In some ways, I would
encourage you as dad
to step in because of
course she goes nuts.
There's a full blown tantrum
that's waiting to happen.
But in some ways,
your child will
benefit knowing that
you're both in charge.
And you can both help in
those kinds of situations
when she's stressed
and distressed, right?
Whether you want to do that or
not is your personal choice.
With a child that's
almost 4 years old,
I think it really
benefits everybody
to have them involved
in the process, which
is acknowledging you put
yourself to sleep, right?
And that's what's missing here.
At bedtime, does she
have an easy time
putting herself to sleep, or
is mom putting her to sleep?
AUDIENCE: We have a
routine where we do books
and we do a song, and
then we put her to bed.
And then we have this
thing called a freebie
where we close the
door, and then she's
like, oh, another kiss and hug.
And we go back in.
And that might happen twice.
And then it's over.
So we do this little
song and dance,
and then she goes to sleep.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
OK, but ultimately, she
goes into her bed, and
she puts herself to sleep?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
AUDIENCE: So she goes
to sleep pretty easily.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
Although some of that stalling--
AUDIENCE: See other stuff--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
--may be evolving, right?
So whether you decide--
whoever decides to get involved
in the middle of the night,
what's really important
is to sit down
with her at a neutral time.
Not at 7:00 PM on a
Monday night, right?
So let's say a weekend,
11:00 AM or something.
And say, honey, you're
not getting healthy sleep.
And it's really time for you to
learn how to put yourself back
to sleep at night.
You can also-- and part of
that discussion should be
acknowledging that putting
yourself to sleep is that
skill, and every
child in a bed--
right?
So it's not good or bad--
every child in a bed
has to put themselves to sleep.
So again, putting the
responsibility and the onus
on her.
You can make a behavior
chart with her.
Now, she may either
say, never mind.
I don't care.
I don't to hear this discussion.
Or she may actually be
interested in learning
what we call sleep manners are.
Sleep manners are just that.
Manners of cooperating at
bedtime, laying in your bed
quietly, and staying
in your bed all night.
And for a child
in this situation,
I would also suggest
putting yourself to sleep,
because that's obviously a goal.
You can do days of the week
with those behaviors, put it up
in the kitchen, and then you
review it every single morning
and say, look, last night you
did a great job cooperating
at bedtime.
You laid quietly in your bed.
You called out at
night, so I know
you had a hard time with that.
But I know you'll
do better tonight.
So it sort of acknowledges that
the responsibility is hers,
and over time you want to build
her up with rewards as she
maintains those behaviors.
And those rewards should always
be an experience, not a thing,
because she's not going
to care about a toy.
Within 24 hours, she's going
to care about stickers--
AUDIENCE: Are stickers a thing?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Stickers
are a thing on the chart.
But what you're trying
to get to, let's say,
after three nights of
all of her manners,
or five nights of
is a trip to the Central
Park Zoo with only mommy
because it's special
mom/daughter time.
We want to reward
with experiences.
So there are definitely going
to be full blown tantrums
for several nights in a row,
particularly a child that's
almost 4.
But if either mom
or you can stay
consistent with that in
saying, I'm saying here,
you lay in bed, you put yourself
to sleep, and sort of maintain
that firm boundary, she should
start getting better about it.
And you may also want
to get that clock
like I mentioned before.
The clock is still
blue for night.
It's nighttime.
It's not time to talk.
It's not time to hang out.
And when the clock
says it's morning,
then we can go spend time
in the kitchen or whatever.
So having that firm boundary
at night is really important.
But giving her the information
ahead of time I think
is key, because she's
completely cognizant and aware.
So that's why I would say cry
it out will probably work.
But I think it's more
respectful to give
her information about how
the rules are changing.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HENRY WEI: So it sounds
like OK hours for sleep.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a Google joke.
So we have a lot more questions.
Let's see if we can get
through all of them.
Next one over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
This is very timely for
me because I actually
have a 3-year-old
and a 6-month-old,
so I have a two part question.
The first is what
are your thoughts
on co-sleeping within a room?
So not in the bed, but
the crib in the bedroom?
Our 6-year-old basically needs
to have a presence there.
Otherwise, she
doesn't go to sleep,
and we have to sit in
a dark room with her.
What are your thoughts?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
So 6-year or 6-month?
AUDIENCE: 6-month-old.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: 6-month.
OK, so the American
Academy of Pediatrics
will recommend room sharing--
which is what you're
talking about--
for the first 12 months.
OK?
And that's--
AUDIENCE: She senses
the presence of somebody
in the room.
And if there's nobody in
there with her, she wakes up
and we have to get
her settled again.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: And
you know, 6-months, she's
still fairly young.
So I wouldn't worry
about it too much.
Room sharing works
for many people.
It doesn't work for everyone.
Some parents find that
it disturbs their sleep
because they hear every little
thing that the baby does,
which doesn't necessarily
need attending to.
And also some parents find
that the baby will sleep better
in a different room.
So I think it's very personal.
But if you're comfortable
with it and you sleep well
and the baby's
doing well, then I
wouldn't worry about
transitioning it
until you feel ready.
AUDIENCE: Well, the
second part of that
is the 3-year-old, he grew up
in a small, New York apartment,
and there was always
somebody in the apartment
in the room with him.
Now he needs a door open.
And we put a gate
up, and we've tried
closing the door at night.
But basically, if he
realizes the door is shut,
there's hell to pay.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
address that for somebody
that's kind of pretty far along
in their behavior and habits?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: I
would say if it's not
disrupting his sleep to
have the door cracked,
let him have it, right?
Because that's obviously a
psychological/control issue.
I want to know that I
can leave and be OK,
and that I am not
completely separate.
And that's OK.
And I am OK with that
as long as there's not
light flooding in and
disturbing his sleep.
You know?
I would let it go.
AUDIENCE: We make sure
that the door's open,
and if the door is closed--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
It's a problem.
AUDIENCE: It's a problem.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
So I would-- that's a
battle I wouldn't fight.
[LAUGHS] There are
too many others
that you probably need to.
HENRY WEI: It's a door's
always open policy over there.
Thank you.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
have a newborn.
She's just 3 weeks, and
obviously, she isn't sleeping.
So my question is what is the
right age to sort of start
all of these habits and--
so right now, she just
falls asleep in our arms.
And we think that's fine
because we don't need sleep.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
[LAUGHS] Of course not.
AUDIENCE: And as soon as
you place her in the crib,
she's up.
So it's the whole
shock factor I think.
But we're fine because
she's just 3 weeks old,
and our pediatrician says
she'll grow out of this.
But we don't know when to
start these kind of habits
like when should we start
having a routine at bedtime?
When should we start basically
following all of this advice?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
So I would say--
I have a question, of course.
You see I have a
lot of questions.
Does she dislike being flat
every time you put her down?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So she's just 3 weeks, but
she goes on her side on her
on every time we
place her on the crib.
Or even with us, she'll
always try to be on the side.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
So being on your side
tends to be where the
contents of your stomach
are the furthest away
from your throat.
So that's usually very
comfortable for babies.
They're not used to being flat.
They're not flat in
utero, and the idea
that the first three
months of a baby's life
is sort of the fourth
trimester, they're
adjusting to being
out of the room.
So that's very common.
I would say that after
the first six weeks
or so, we really want to see
a gentle schedule developing
where the clock
is not a dictator,
but the clock is a guide.
Gee, I see you've been
awake for almost two hours.
You must be very tired.
I'm going to get ready to put
you down for sleep, right?
Whether that's during
the day or at night.
So at about 6 to
8 weeks, I think
that it's a great time
to have a good gentle
routine for the evening and
bedtime and just start shaping
things, looking at
the clock, trying
to follow a gentle schedule.
So right now, she
doesn't have the energy
to stay awake through a feeding
and all the other things that
go on, and that's
typically that's completely
typical and normal.
I do encourage
parents to just get
the baby used to wherever
they're going to sleep.
Bassinet, crib.
Again, putting them down
three to five minutes so
that they look around,
they experience the place.
It's OK, I'm fine, I can be
in here, it's not stressful.
I don't just wake
up in this place,
and I don't remember
how I got here.
So if you can do that once
or twice a day, great.
And then at 6 to 8
weeks, can she gradually
start falling asleep in
the crib or bassinet?
Can you put her down
and see if she'll fall
asleep there one time a day?
Just once.
If not, if there's a lot of
crying, pick her up, move on,
don't worry about it.
So at this point, just getting
her use to a gentle schedule
is great.
And if you can do
that by 6 to 8 weeks,
you're in a very good place.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
HENRY WEI: Great.
Let's go for just two more.
And then I'll remind folks that
goodnightssleepcoaching.com
is Christina Gantcher's site.
Over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
We're new parents in the room.
We did extinction at 4 months,
and it worked really well
for us.
Within five days, he
slept through the night.
He's 5 months now, so
it was a month ago.
So no major sleep problems yet.
But we travel every
weekend in the summer.
It's a four hour drive.
And I'm pretty scared to
start doing that with him.
He's already done the
drive when he was younger,
but it was before we
were really on a schedule
and doing a bedtime routine.
So my plan for now is to start
his routine in the apartment,
give him his bottle,
read his book,
put him in his pajamas,
his nighttime diaper,
put him in the car at 7:00 when
we normally put him to sleep,
and have him fall
asleep in the car,
and then move him to a crib.
It's worked once already.
But do you suggest
that I wake him up
when we try to move
him to the crib
so that he remembers I'm
not in the car anymore.
I'm in a crib.
Or if he's sleeping, put him in
the crib and just let him be?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: I would just
transfer as gently as you can.
Because behaviorally,
it's not as
if you need him to remember
that you're transferring him.
You're not going to start
the whole routine again
at whatever time you arrive,
so it sort of doesn't matter.
And fingers crossed that he
handles that transfer easily
and moves on, and that's OK.
And at this age, he's 5
months, so 6, 7, 8 months,
it may work fairly well for him.
You know?
I think it's toughest when we
try to do that at around a year
or so because most babies tend
to be very cognizant of what's
going on, and they won't
always transfer easily anymore.
So fingers crossed that
it could work well.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then a quick
second question.
It hasn't happened yet, but
I'm terrified for teething
because he's such a
good sleeper already.
Any general tips for night
wakings as it impacts teething?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: So
teething is one of these things
that you expect a tooth,
and four months later, it
comes out, right?
[LAUGHS] It can last months.
And also, we want to recognize
that teething happens all day.
It doesn't just happen at
1:00 in the morning, right?
So if your child is waking
up and you think, oh, it
must be teething, you're seeing
signs all day long, right?
It's not just in the
middle of the night.
There's really only
two things I suggest.
Number one, ask
your pediatrician
what to give your
child before bedtime
and potentially have it ready
for the middle of the night,
right?
And be consistent
with your behavior.
It doesn't mean that you get
to backslide and do anything
differently, because getting
into some other behavioral
habit is not going
to help the teething.
AUDIENCE: So you're
a fan of extinction,
for example, where we didn't go
in at all when he was crying.
And he cries in the
middle of the night,
and we suspected-- we've checked
his temperature, he's not sick.
He doesn't have a dirty diaper.
We suspect it might be teething.
Do you just then let him cry,
or give him something to soothe?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
I would-- whatever your
pediatrician suggests
between Motrin, Advil, Tylenol.
I would definitely
give that, and then--
out of the room.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yeah, sure.
HENRY WEI: OK, one last
question over here.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
I have a 22-month-old daughter
who sleeps through the night,
but she sleeps through the night
in our bed, which is definitely
not what I want.
My wife seems
ambivalent towards it.
But we have another baby
coming in September.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK
AUDIENCE: So what's the
best way to transfer
her back to her crib?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
OK, so she has a crib
in her own room or your room?
AUDIENCE: In her own room.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
AUDIENCE: Which we've started
trying to put her in for naps,
and that works most of the time.
So she'll nap in her crib, but
at night time, it's a pattern.
So she'll go with her mom,
and she takes a long time
to fall asleep.
So like half hour to
an hour most nights
of singing or just whatever.
My wife will go to
bed with her and get
her to sleep before she
goes asleep in the bed.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: Right.
And what time is that time?
AUDIENCE: She varies.
And she likes to go
to bed late, so--
well--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: What time?
AUDIENCE: But it
doesn't matter what time
we put her to bed, that
half hour to an hour rule
kind of holds.
She's just active no
matter what happens, and--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: So were
you talking about late being
like 8:30, 9:00, or like 11:00?
AUDIENCE: No, no.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
AUDIENCE: 9:00-ish.
8:00 to 9:00 is usual time.
CHRISTINA GANTCHER: OK.
So I would say it's
great that you have her
in the crib during the day.
Keep doing that for sure.
I would probably just
pick a time that's
really convenient
for both of you
and say, OK, starting
this Friday night,
she's falling to sleep.
She's falling asleep
at bedtime in her crib.
It's going to be tantrums
for several nights.
If you think-- if you and your
wife decide that you can do it,
it will probably be
easier for your daughter
to do that separation.
You can stay with her
and say, I'm here.
You're in your crib.
I'm here until you fall asleep.
AUDIENCE: All right,
so moving-- yes.
So the extinction is
probably bad for her
because of the
attachment kind of thing.
So it would be better to do
one of the other methods?
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
Yes, I totally
agree because she's really used
to having a physical presence,
right?
So let's say you stay with her
for several nights in a row.
Then you gradually start moving
yourself out of the room,
so you're by the doorway
or in the hallway.
And you're sort of coaching
her, but not doing it
for her anymore.
AUDIENCE: OK.
HENRY WEI: All right.
Well, thank you, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you to the Talks at
Google team and the event team.
And thank you Christina
Gantcher so much--
CHRISTINA GANTCHER:
Thank you for having me.
HENRY WEI: --for coming
and sharing your expertise.
And sweet dreams everyone.
[APPLAUSE]